[Music]
and this is new for you here at six
o'clock emotional testimony for a bill
that would allow permanently ill people
to take a pill prescribed by a doctor to
end their life it's dubbed Medical Aid
in dying Senate Bill 239 had its first
hearing today patients would have to be
terminally ill with six months or less
to live mentally capable and also over
18. a 57 year old grandmother dying of
terminal cancer testified in support
this bill may not become law in time for
me but I believe it should become law
for those in need and there are many
people in Nevada in need right now
I am a strong believer in the circle of
life I'm a Believer in God I know that
it's my timing but I don't think I or my
family should have to see me suffer
now Democrats are proposing this
Republicans raising questions about
things like how the cause of death would
be listed if this passes Nevada would be
the 12th state to allow it assisted
dying bills have been brought up in the
last couple of sessions here in Nevada
though none have passed also a new bill
could potentially increase your property
taxes right now property tax hikes are
capped at three percent every year
Senate Bill 96 will let them go up by as
much as eight percent but not less than
3 percent Democratic state senator Dina
Neal says it would help stabilize
government budgets opponents arguing
that more than half the nation already
is living paycheck to paycheck this
would need approval of two-thirds of
both houses to pass the legislature the
majority of public comment on this
against the proposal